[Musique]
ton
ans
[Musique]
en
oh
[Musique]
en
hahaha
[Musique]
à
ans
non
en
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
et
[Musique]
oh
et
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
et à
waka
pétain
bédard
oh
colas
[Musique]
parti tout
car
m
ted rogers
pow pow pow
[Musique]
de temps en temps
paul
[Musique]
oui
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
non
[Musique]
bonsoir vous avez pu assister au tout
début une performance qui s'appelle bull
qui bull qui est une performance que
j'ai réalisé la première fois dans la
galerie p38 dans le 18ème arrondissement
de paris et elle venait de sites cités
d'art ça fait 15 ans à peu près que je
pratique le graffiti et je voulais
montrer la beauté qui existe dans le tag
est dans le graffiti il ya une manière
bien spécifique dont j'aborde le tag
c'est de manière très dense et ce qui
m'intéresse c'est la gestuelle et
comment rendre compte cette gestuelle
dans une pratique qui est illégal celle
du tag et l'a montré en institution
c'était la question principale est donc
fort de cette expérience de 15 ans de
graffitis j'ai voulu montrer réellement
cette beauté cette gestuelle ces
mouvements qui existe dans le graffiti
dans le tag
il faut savoir que moi je considère le
tag et le graffiti de manière illégale
c'est à dire dans un contexte bien
particulier qui est celui de la rue et
il y à des intempéries il ya des
interactions avec les gens on est
susceptible d'être arrêté par la police
et tout ça crée un contexte bien
particulier qui vous met dans un état
spécifique qui peut être du stress on
peut se retrouver avec la boule au
ventre
on peut très bien être détendu parce
qu'aucun passants et là à côté de vous
ou bien sinon on peut être aussi dans un
état peut être aussi d'apothéose on peut
les se laisser aller et faire des traits
dans tous les sens ce qui m'intéresse
moi c'est d'enchaîner les lettres les
unes avec les autres
c'est à dire que j'ai un blaze un nom
que je me suis créé mozac m os à et
l'intérêt du talent pour moi c'est
d'enchaîner ces lettres là le m va être
arrondi à instant chesnais avec un os
qui va être un peu plus grands un ace
qui va être minuscule est un acquis va
ressembler à un coeur et qui va partir
et donc dans l'idée comment montrer
cette gestuelle ce mouvement là qui est
in situ donc j'ai commencer par analyser
mes mouvements savoir comment je me
plaçais par rapport au mur
comment je me comment je me plaçais par
rapport aux murs et aussi à la manière
dont j'interagis c'est avec les passants
qui étaient autour de moi et donc du
coup vous pouvez voir ici la première
vidéo que j'ai réalisé qu'ils
s'appellent slow momo une vidéo en slow
motion où j'ai pu analyser tous mes
mouvements au ralenti il faut savoir
aussi que c'était la première fois que
j'ai utilisée aussi un costume et le
costume vu qu'on se crée une nouvelle
identité
c'était tout simplement de pouvoir aussi
jouer sur sept nouveaux rôles qu'on se
donnait dans la rue par rapport à la
gestuelle et au mouvement qui est pour
moi primordial dans la pratique du tag
j'ai voulu essayer de pouvoir l'exprimer
de manière très simple et de manière
très compréhensible il faut savoir que
je suis au tagueur graffeurs mais aussi
artiste plasticien et j'ai toujours eu
ce dialogue ce parallèle entre ma
pratique en atelier et celle dans la rue
et donc comment montrer cette gestuelle
j'en ai créé un système un système qui
s'appelle bull qui un système qui
reprendrait chaque point du corps ayant
un mouvement bien particulier et que je
pourrais transmettre à un danseur et
donc dans l'idée j'ai voulu vraiment
essayé d'analyser comprendre mon
positionnement dans la rue et dans un
contexte qui est vraiment celui de la
rue c'est très important le contexte de
la rue parce que c'est ça qui donne
toute la puissance et la beauté aux tags
par exemple ça ne m'intéresse pas de
pouvoir de reproduire un tag sur une
toile et de la montrer dans une galerie
est juste de l'accrocher comme cela pour
moi c'est vide de sens ethiquement c'est
impossible pour moi il y à une mode
celle du street art actuellement qui
s'intéressent juste au final à la
graphie qui existent où on va demander à
des artistes issus de milieux urbains ou
de la rue de reproduire ce qu'ils font
tout simplement sur toile ça ne
m'intéresse pas et c'est aussi un
positionnement par rapport au moment où
mouvement street art actuel pour moi le
street art c'est une énorme corbeil dans
lequel on va mettre des gens qui font
des pochoirs des gens qui font de la
peinture des gens qui font du graffiti
du talent et au final on ne sait même
plus à quoi ça correspond il faut savoir
que il y a une une histoire du graffiti
si on l'apprend cdh à la fin des années
70 début 80 avec les premiers artiste
graffiti qui s'est exprimé sur des
trains et donc du coup fort d'une
expérience favola l'histoire du graffiti
elle est quand même de 50 ans donc au
bout d'un moment il s'agit aussi de
ramener quelque chose de nouveau et un
nouveau positionnement
moi ça a été celui du corps de la
gestuelle et du mouvement et donc vous
pouvez voir ici les partitions que j'ai
créé suite au système que j'ai créé et
c'était là c'est ici une partition que
j'ai fait à la galerie clacs bosse à
paris et donc du coup au tout début j'ai
créé ces partitions que je donnais aux
danseurs et au final j'ai su m'adapter
et ce qui m'intéresse dans le graffiti
c'est vraiment la liberté c'est
l'improvisation et donc du coup de
travailler avec des danseurs j'ai voulu
aussi laisser libre cours à
l'improvisation avec les gens avec qui
je travaillais c'est très important pour
moi c'est ce qui redynamise aussi mon
art city si une autre partition une
partition qui est étendue aux vous
pouvez voir cette fois la superposition
de deux partitions de deux lignes et
c'est une partition que j'ai réalisé
pour le premier acte au palais de tokyo
en juin dernier
il faut savoir aussi que ces partitions
ont une valeur esthétique certes mais
elles ont aussi une valeur d' archives
c'est à dire une partie une part de
risque une performance elle est à un
moment donné comme vous venez de vivre
cette expérience
quelques minutes auparavant et ce qui
m'intéresse est de lui donner aussi une
valeur pérenne donc des archives et si
je voulais considère aussi ses pinceaux
comme des archives
ici vous voyez une partition que
j'appelais bull qui 2.0 j'essaye de
faire avancer ce système là et d'essayer
d'emmener ses systèmes chorégraphique
vers de nouveaux horizons pouvez voir
ici par exemple les dernières études que
je suis en train de faire en sachant que
les points rouges représentent des temps
de pause et les liaisons
qui existent entre les différentes
partitions qui se succèdent ramènerait
comme des sortes de raccourcis donc
laisser libre court aussi aux danseurs
de prendre un point rouge par exemple et
de descendre sur une autre partition est
de pouvoir enchaîner les mouvements et
qui se sentent libres de l'interpréter
il y a aussi le rapport à la rue qui est
évident dans ma pratique
de la performance et elle n'est pas
juste a présenté sous forme de spectacle
ou d'happening dans des lieux institut
n'y alizée ou comme ici dans un théâtre
il ya aussi la rue j'aime aussi cette
idée de revenir à la rue dans l'espace
public
c'est très important pour moi dans dans
la pratique du tag elle peut s'assimiler
une sorte de petit terrorisme dans le
sens où on se donne le droit de pouvoir
tag est là où on veut quand on veut
j'aime aussi cette idée là de pouvoir
faire des performances à n'importe quel
moment et dans n'importe quel lieu et du
coup ici c'était à la galerie le module
dans le 18ème arrondissement de paris où
j'ai organisé cette performance dans un
contexte urbain
il ya quelque chose aussi de deux très
importants dans la dans la question de
la performance quand on se pose la
question de la performance on se pose
aussi la question du costume et donc du
coup ses costumes ses références
viennent de des pays que j'ai que j'ai
pu visiter tel que le liban la syrie ou
encore la tunisie et donc du coup c'est
un mélange de plein d'influencés
influence aussi au niveau de la culture
géorgienne au niveau du tag et de
l'alphabet mais aussi du du du costume
la façon dont il est traité sur ce coton
qui est rouge ça rappelle aussi la
manière du tag avec le dripping les
lunettes sont des lunettes des années 60
peut être aussi d'influencer hippie et
donc on joue on joue sur plein de
références qui viennent au final créer
une une chorégraphie y ait une
performance bien singulière ce qui
m'intéresse c'est aussi la création d'un
personnage vu que dans le graffiti on se
crée un blaze un pseudonyme mois mozac
pourquoi ne pas créer un personnage dans
toute sa complexité et donc du coup j'ai
voulu créer ce personnage qui
viendraient être comme une sorte
voilà deux personnages fictionnels qui
viendraient interpréter les rôles que je
lui donne est donc j'ai voulu aussi
travaillé sur l'aspect fantomatique
l'aspect aussi qui peut faire penser
aussi à la burqa qui sont des références
aussi par rapport à ce que j'aime en
fiction ou bien même en science fiction
avec des oeuvres telles que philippe
druillet ou bien même des oeuvres comme
star wars et donc il faut
j'aime aussi cette cet aspect voilà
énigmatique fantomatique voire même
spirituelle ici vous pouvez voir le
dernier tissu que j'ai fait pour la
performance qui s'appelle nous sont
tunisie donc là avec un aspect beaucoup
plus touareg avec un chèche qui vient
aussi cacher comme dans la pratique du
graffiti où on se cache la notion de
masquer d'identité m'intéresse vraiment
ici la performance nous en tunisie et
donc au final ce qui m'intéresse en
partant de la pratique du tag qui est
une pratique qui relève réellement de
lego car on appose son nom comment
pouvoir créer un univers fictionnel où
chacun des personnages que je viendrais
créé animerait une fiction est donc ce
qui m'intéresse au final c'est de créer
une cosmogonie voilà je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]